翻訳: Yuta Kawamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
今日は 消極性デザインという考え方について
お話ししに来ました
私は 大学の先生をしていますので
こういうプレゼンの場は
普通の人よりは慣れている方だと思うんです
でも今 かなり見てわかる通り緊張しています
（笑）
そんな緊張しいな私が
プレゼンよりも もっと緊張してしまうのが
懇親会というやつです
大きな学会なんかになりますと
大きな部屋に 100人以上の人が集まって
思い思いに話をして仲良くなって
時には その後一緒に
研究をするようになったりする
そういうイベントです
私も最初は あのすごい発表をしていた人と
お話してみたいと —
声をかけてみようと思ったりしてるんです
でも その人はすでに他の人と
話が弾んでいたりして
私なんかと話しても
面白くないかもしれないな などと
考えすぎてしまってるうちに
気がつけば わたしだけひとりかと
せめて恥ずかしいから
知り合いを探して話しかけようと
そんなふうにしているうちに
終わってしまうということがあります
学生でも社会人でも
きっと同じようなイベントがあって
私と同じように 消極的に
なってしまってる人っていると思うんです
もしかしたら
「そんなところに立っているだけでも
積極的な方じゃないか」とか
「１回は 声かけてみようと
思うんでしょう？」とか
「私ならそもそも とても消極的だから
懇親会なんか参加しないし」と
いうふうに言いたくなった人も
いるかもしれません
でも 一つ言わせてください
そういう「私の方が消極的」
「私こそが本物の消極的」みたいに
張り合うのはやめにしましょう
（笑）
だって今時 誰にだって
消極的になってしまうときがある
そういう時代だからです
わかりやすいのは
Twitter だと思います
私 Twitter 好きで
よくするんですけれども
いろんな人からフォローされます
でも別に フォローし返さなくてもいいし
フォローしたいだけして
コミュニケーションもしたいだけする
そういうとても受身でいられる
頑張らなくてもいいところが受けている
そういうアプリだと思うんです
そういうアプリが受けている時代に
懇親会だからといって 頑張るっていうのは
何か違うんじゃないかと
私は思います
懇親会だって 頑張らなくても
コミュニケーションできればいいなと
私は常々思っています
そんな話をしていると
「いや もっと積極的になりなよ」と
お叱りになりたい人も
中にはいるかもしれません
でもそういう人も もともとは消極的で
気合でうまくできるようになってきたからこそ
「自分もできたんだから
お前も気合で何とかしろ」と
そういうふうな人が
多いんじゃないかと思うんです
でも 私はその気合いを
もっと別のことに向けたらいいのに
というふうに考えてしまいます
コミュニケーションが楽になれば
そのエネルギーをもっと
他のことに向けられるんじゃないか
というふうに思うんです
話を懇親会に戻しましょう
（笑）
懇親会も「懇親会します」というだけで
うまく交流できる人ばかりじゃないな
というふうなことを考えて
ちょっと工夫してみようというふうに
考えてくれる人も中にいます
[TEDxKobe オーガナイザーの写真]
そうすると私はですね
「そういう懇親会なら私でも
上手く交流できるかもしれない」と
いうふうに期待を胸に
参加してみるわけです
でもいざふたを開けてみると
ジェスチャーゲームが始まったりするんですね
（笑）
ジェスチャーゲーム —
「今からお題を出しますので
ジェスチャーだけでそれを表現してください
豪華景品を用意してますので
頑張ってください」と そんなゲームです
「うわ〜 やりたくない」と
思うんですよね
（笑）
でも 言う勇気がありません
周りにもきっと そんな人がいるはずです
「せめて難しいお題は勘弁してくれ —
野球ぐらいにしておいてくれ」
という心の声が私には聞こえてきます
しかし その願いはもろくも打ち砕かれ
流行りのお笑い芸人のネタをいきなり人前で
やらされることになったりするわけです
イベントの主催者をするような人っていうのは
だいたい積極的な人で
そういう「盛り上がればなんとかなる」と
いうふうな考え方をする人が
多いように思います
（笑）
私は「これはそういう人には
任せておけない」と
（笑）
「消極的な私のような人が
何とかするしかないな」と
いうふうに思うようになったんです
ある学会で私は
「夕食席決めシステム」
というものをつくることになりました
どういうシステムかというと
パソコンとかスマートフォンで事前に
「誰々さんと近くの席になりたい」
というふうに
こっそりと登録しておくことができると
そうしておくと
システムが自動的に
なるべく多くの人の願いを叶えてくれるように
席を決めてくれる そういうシステムです
そんなシステムがあれば
私も 憧れのあの人と
お話できるかもしれない —
そんな懇親会なら参加してみたい —
というふうに思ってくれた人も
いるかもしれません
でも 私は何しろ消極的なので
まだそれでは安心できませんでした
憧れの人とめでたくシステムが隣の席に
してくれたときのことを想像してみましょう
「なんでこの人と隣になったんだ？
私は この人と話したいと登録してない」
「なるほど この人は 私と話したいと
登録したんだ」というふうに
希望がばれてしまうんです
（笑）
それだったら「お隣いいですか」と言って
座って行くのと同じでないかと —
それができないから苦労したのに
というふうに私は思いました
せっかく大掛かりなシステムを
わざわざ作るんだったら
消極的な人が 安心して交流できるような
システムを作りたいと
何よりも私が安心して参加したい
というふうに思ったんです
そこで 私がどうしたかというと
希望の登録の仕方を変えました
私が誰々さんと近くになりたい
というふうに登録するのではなくて
AさんとBさんが近くの席になったらいいな
というふうに登録できる —
そんなシステムにしました
そうすると ２人の人を仲人のように
引き合わせてあげるイメージですね
そういうシステムです
もちろん
どちらかの名前を
こっそりと自分にしておけば
自分の希望も登録することができる
そういうシステムです
もう一度 憧れの人と隣の席になった
ときのことをイメージしてみましょう
相手はやっぱり
「何でこの人と隣になったんだろう —
この人が私と話したかったのかな」
というふうに思います
「でも待てよ —
他の人が登録したのかもしれない」
「分からないな」というふうに
希望がばれにくくなるというわけです
（笑）
難しいことではないんです
非常にちょっとした工夫です
でも よっぽど消極的な人でなければ
そこまで工夫しようとは考えません
消極的だからこそ
消極的な人が安心して参加できる
そういう工夫を考えることはできるんです
私は そういう工夫のことを
「消極性デザイン」と呼んでいます
英語では「Shyhack（シャイハック）」
と呼んでいます
消極性で悩んでる人っていうのは
なかなか他の人に
「私こういうことで悩んでる」
ということは言えないということも
あると思います
そもそも 消極性で悩んでる
ということに関しては
普通の人は 「努力や根性で解決しよう」
というふうに思い込んでいますので
なかなかそういう発想すら出てきにくい
ということがあるんじゃないかなと思います
そういう空気が 少しずつでも変わって
消極性の問題も 工夫で何とかしてみよう
というふうに思ってくれる人が増えたら
私は嬉しいです
とは言っても
「システムを作るのは難しいんでしょう」
「プログラミングとか
しなきゃいけないんでしょう」
「それだったら
まだ積極的になるほうが簡単そう」
そんなふうに もしかしたら思われた人も
いるかもしれません
確かに 私は消極的で緊張しいなんですけど
プログラミングは得意だったので
そういうシステムをつくることができました
でも 私もいつも主催者なわけではないので
プログラミングができたからといって
いつも私のシステムを使ってもらえる
わけではありません
そんな 一参加者として参加するときでも
私は何かしらのShyhackを
準備していきます
私が今 一番お気に入りの
Shyhackは
好きなもののTシャツを着ていく
というものです
今も着てるんですけれども —
Twitterが好きなんですね
こういう格好をして懇親会に参加すると
向こうの方から
「Twitter好きなんですか？」
「Twitterやるんですか？」と
声をかけてもらうことができます
自分から声をかけなくていいというだけでも
かなり救われます
しかもTwitterの話をすればいいので —
自分の好きなものの話をすればいいので
自分の土俵の上で戦うことができると
そういうShyhackです
（笑）
もっとやる気がないときもあります
今度の懇親会どうしても
参加しなきゃいけないらしいんだけども
話をする気力もないと
そんなときもあります
そのとき私は ちょっといい
ごついカメラを首から下げていきます
そうすると 会場に一人でいたとしても
私は懇親会の撮影係に見えるんです
（笑）
一人でいても恥ずかしくないと —
そういうShyhackです
もしかしたら「写真撮ってください」ぐらいは
声をかけられることがあるかもしれませんが
写真を撮ればいいんです
もし「ラッキー！この人とお話してみたい！」
という人が近づいてきたときには
「実は私は 撮影係じゃなくて
参加者なんです」と
言ってお話すればいいという —
そういう Twitterのような気軽さがある
Shyhackだと思っています
どうでしょう？それぐらいなら
私でもできるかもという気がしてきませんか
消極的な人が
自分の悩みを自分で解決すれば
同じような悩みで苦しんでいる消極的な人 —
あるいは 気合で何とかうまくできてる人
そんな人たちが少しずつ楽になります
消極的な人は
そういう解決した方がいい問題に
いち早く気づくことができる
優れた才能の持ち主だと私は思っています
皆さんの心の中にある消極性の数だけ
消極性デザインの種はあります
私と違って 懇親会は大好きなんだけど
プレゼンは すごくあがってしまって
だめだめなんですという人も
いるかもしれません
コミュニケーションは
だいたい大丈夫なんだけど
何か新しいことを始めようと思っても
すぐやめてしまう —
三日坊主になってしまうんですというふうに
悩んでいる人もいるかもしれません
だいたい私はいつも積極的なんだけど
異性と話すときだけ
ピンポイントに消極的になってしまう
という人もいるかもしれません
皆さん そんな自分をどうやったら
変えられるだろうと 長年悩んできた
でも もしかしたら変えられなかった
私は 違う方法を試してみるべきだ
というふうに思います
ぜひ皆さん
自分なりの
消極性デザインを考えてみてください
これは先生からの宿題です
（笑）
ありがとうございました
（拍手）